[Music]
hello welcome
I'm Huntsville I'm a software engineer
in the Android runtime group and I'm
here to talk to you about how to manage
native C++ from memory in Android
generally most Android applications are
written in Java today maybe Catalan in
the future but there are sometimes
reasons to also write pieces of the
application in C or C++ code it may be
the case that you can implement some
algorithm more efficiently in the
language like C++ or you may have a
native library that already exists that
you wanted to use or the like here we're
really talking about multi-language
applications that combines a Java and
C++ and it turns out that even if you're
in the business of writing a hundred
percent Java apps as you maybe some of
what I'm going to talk about what may
still occur may still be an issue in
certain isolated cases for example if
you look at the Android platform
implementation the big integer
implementation that you're using if you
bake it using big integer at all is
actually implemented in terms of native
code underneath and that may in other
cases that sort of thing may actually
show too so that was one of the reasons
I got involved in this I actually spent
some time working on the Android
calculator app which happens to be a
major client of big integer and here
we're going to use a running example of
a hypothetical C++ package that we want
to access from Java language code that
manipulates polynomials over GF 2 does
anybody know what that means good you're
not supposed to it doesn't matter as far
as we're concerned these are basically
bit vectors with an odd notion of
multiplication but I don't even care
about that I'm not going to show you the
C++ code actually in this this
particular example is good because it
turns out that in spite of
fact that it seems esoteric modern
Harvard often has a hardware support for
this so you can actually build a
blazingly fast really low-level
implementation so what we want to do is
we have this library and we want to call
that library from Java code so what this
looks like roughly is the following it's
because that you see up here so the
important part here is we have a Java
class which logically owns a C++ object
that actually contains the guts of the
implementation that actually implements
the the real functionality which I'm not
going to show you what the Java object
holds is a Java long which is really a
C++ pointed in disguise this then what
it's going to do is for example when you
want to multiply two of these this is
eventually going to call this native
multiply function it's going to pass it
to Java Long's this is going to go into
some J&I code which will cast those Java
Long's to C++ pointers and manipulate
the C++ object and in this particular
case we turn another Java long which is
really a C++ pointer so the the Java
level multiplication routine is really
one that just gives me back a new binary
poly object containing this Java long
which really points to C++ code which I
obtained by I obtained the the
underlying the underlying C++ pointer by
calling this native multiply routine so
what here's a pictorial representation
of what this looks like I have a the
Java object at the top of the slide
which is the only thing that the job
that my client actually sees so I want
the client to be able to treat this Java
object as though it were implemented
completely in Java and ignore the fact
that the C++ code underneath the
dot-dash line here is the Java long
which is really a C++ pointer which sort
of points to the C++ object reference
though Java doesn't know that and inside
the C++ object representation there may
be additional pointers that point to
additional C++ data structures so what's
the problem with doing this the problem
comes into play when we try to think
about how objects how memory gets
managed and how objects get be allocated
on the on the Java language side we have
a garbage collector that cleans up after
us and we generally don't have to worry
about this too much when things are no
longer reference they go away when they
become unreachable they go away on the
c++ side we have a manual memory
management discipline usually which
means we explicitly need to call some
delete functions and bolita in order to
deallocate the memory when it's no
longer reachable and so how do we
actually do that we have to arrange for
somebody to call the delete function on
the c++ object so here's the traditional
way to do this and the point of this
talk is largely to talk you out of doing
it this way so the traditional way of
doing this which has the attraction
admittedly that it's relatively simple
to write the code compared to what I'm
going to show you is that in addition to
things like the native multiply method
I'll have a native delete method to
which I also pass a job along and then
the native delete method will again
convert that to the C++ pointer and
invoke delete on it or invoke the
appropriate D leader on it and I will
call this I will call that native delete
from a java finalizer
the finalizer is invoked more or less
when the object becomes unreachable so
that then goes ahead and invoke the ADT
Leeton correctly allocates the c++
object as well I'll show you some
reasons why this is problematic here so
I'll go through a long list of finalizer
of finalizer problems finalizes have a
deserved reputation for being hazardous
and I'll only confirm that here but I'll
actually emphasize some some relatively
lesser known problems which in my
opinion actually the
serious ones to try to get to get come
to grips with and then I'll show you how
to work around those so the the first
problem is that if two objects become
unreachable the finalizes actually run
in arbitrary order that includes the
case in which two objects that point to
each other become unreachable at the
same time they can be finalized in the
wrong order meaning that the the second
one to be finalized actually try to
access an object that's already been
finalized I'll go into some more details
there so as a result of that what can
happen is that you can get dangling
pointers and CD allocated C++ objects
the thing to keep in mind here is that
as a result of dangling pointers in this
environment is that you and very often
end up corrupting the c++ c but what's
the math the the java language runtime
actually relies on the c++ heap as well
so what if when this happens often what
you end up with is also a compacted Java
Runtime and you may end up seeing caches
that actually look like Java garbage
collector caches or the like so here's
to illustrate how this can go on here's
a sample client application that
actually uses the binary poly class that
we just talked about and this is this in
combination with the previous class will
definitely break so definitely do not do
this so what this is doing in its
finalized method it's just doing
something innocuous on my binary poly
which is this field that happens to hold
a pointer to the binary poly now the
problem here is that it's entirely
possible that the my binary poly object
actually gets finalized first so what
you're accessing here is in my binary
poly which actually has already been
finalized so by the time you you access
it the pointer the c++ object underlying
it will have been de-allocated and the
native pointer that you're using
actually points to nowhere so that's a
bad thing
there's the second problem with
finalizes which is actually it turns out
to be more complicated to work around in
it's less employ less important on
Android but it's generally important
when writing java language code so by
Java language rules and this is not
currently - on Android and not currently
believed to be true on Android and
object X is finalized it may actually be
invoked while one of X's methods is
still running so while while I'm still
running a method on that object that
object may end up getting finalized this
can result in the same sort of
phenomenon I get native heat corruption
as and as a result possibly Java Runtime
corruption
let me explain why that happens so
here's sort of again an excerpt from the
binary poly class I have I used native
mobile I use multiply before I'll use it
again here's I have this native multiply
method that gets called by multiply if
you look at what this actually gets
compiled to and this isn't real this is
sort of pseudocode
pseudocode it gets compiled to look
something like this so what happens when
I want to multiply to two values I first
end up leaving the the native handles
from both of them in this case from this
and I may put this in here explicitly to
make that clear
so I repeat and native handle from this
and I repeat and they don't handle from
other then I might allocate the new
binary poly object and then I will go
ahead and call the native method so the
problem with this is if we look at the
uses of the actual Java objects the last
use of this and other actually happened
before allocate the new binary poly at
that point from that point on this
method doesn't use either this or other
anymore
and it may so happen that this is in
fact the last call on those so this is
in fact the point at which those become
garbage and the garbage collected
notices that they're no longer teachable
so what can happen at that point if the
if the ad is designed to allow this and
if all the stalls line up just right it
can in fact happen that the garbage
collector at that point besides that
these are no longer that this and other
no longer needed and arrange for the
finalizes on both of those to get it
vote roughly where the new binary poly
happens occurs what then happens is that
when we call native multiply we don't
need the objects anymore but we still
need the native handles but now the
native handles that would be allocated
so in fact I'm accessing objects that
are no longer around this is allowed by
the Java language specification and it's
something that that has been seen on the
ground occasion in the wild but it
doesn't happen very often there are more
problems with finalizes you can see a
lot of them by looking at the joshua
blocks effective java book which
actually has a section on the on
entitled I believe avoid finalizes one
one thing to indicate the problems is
that it's actually the plan as I believe
to deprecate finalized and finalized in
JDK 9 another issue which I look at
occasional here a little bit is that for
these for this to work correctly and if
you run an application that allocates
lots of native memory and relatively
little Java memory it may actually not
be the case that you the garbage
collector runs fondly enough to actually
invoke finalizes or the other mechanism
also just in a minute here so you
actually may have to invoke these
systems RTC and system to run
finalization occasionally which is
tricky to do because if you do it too
much it will greatly slow down your
application and many people have fallen
into that trap there's a more subtle
issue that they sometimes finalize those
actually
extend the lifetime of the Java object
for another garbage collection cycle
which means for generational garbage
collected they may actually cause it to
survive into the old generation that it
may be the lifetime may be greatly
extended as a result of just having a
finalizar
and there are other issues which I won't
go into here so how do you really delete
C++ objects I should point out the usual
advice here which I'll skim over briefly
is to use explicit clothes and tie with
resources so Java has a syntactic
facility which allow us essentially C++
style distraction when you leave a scope
you can arrange to to explicitly call
the close function and that works when
it's applicable so there cases like file
like object system allocated objects and
torn with it's generally that I approach
and that's the main recommendation on
the other hand there are many cases in
my experience where that doesn't work
and in general people already use this
wing in those cases where it where it's
applicable so for example if I mention C
is the java.lang big integer and example
in the platform you really don't want to
have to call big integer that close
every time one of those goes out of
scope that would be completely untenable
and there are many or more examples like
that in the Android platform I should
warn you that for what are the solutions
I'm talking about a lot of this is
actually not fully settled in the
community as a whole this is sort of
beyond Android as well it's still trying
to figure out what the right way to do
this is these are mostly sort of general
Java language issues that are actually
not specific to Android but there seems
to be it seems to be agreement that you
shouldn't use object not finalized as
evidenced by the fact that it's going to
be deprecated sometime in the future so
the advice here and I'll go into how to
do this is we use something called
java.lang graph phantom reference and
many of you may have encountered that as
far as I can tell most people look at it
and ignore it because it's it's somewhat
complicated probably appears even more
complicated than it actually is it's not
really commonly used but it actually is
a better replacement for finalizes it
avoids the problem that the finalizar
can see finalized objects because of the
ordering issues phantom references
ensure that you run the cleanup code
only when the object really is about to
go away and nobody can use it and nobody
can see it anymore
it suddenly deals with finalized
application issues it's not going away
it also ends up dealing with some of the
more subtle issues though not all of
them it does not feel with the premature
cleanup issue that I mentioned earlier
that an object can be finalized while
one of its methods is still running for
example the major difficulty with using
it and I'll go through an example here
is that it's relatively complicated to
use at the moment and we're in the
process of making that better I think
various groups are in the process of
making that better so Java 9 actually
has this notion of a cleaner which makes
this a little bit simpler weave inside
the platform we actually have something
called native allocation registry that
deals with some of this this is at the
moment not a public API but if you're
interested in this we're trying to
assess whether it would be good to make
that a public API or whether and whether
this is the right API to do that with so
what should you use instead well I
mentioned these phantom references so
what are they a phantom reference is
shown here with the ghost next to it
it's an object that's associated with
the object whose lifetime you want to
monitor so it doesn't actually it
doesn't actually point to or equal to
the the binary poly object that we want
monitored and then we want to be cleaned
up after so you can sort of think of the
phantom reference as the last will and
testament of the years of Java object
it tells you what to do how to clean up
the object once a die once the Java
object dies and so both the the way this
works normally in order to actually use
a phantom reference you'll usually
inherit from it and the inherited
derived class the Class VI from Phantom
reference will have a pointer to the C++
object along with the the Java binary
poly object there's also a reference
queue off to the side here which I'll
show you what all that plays in a second
here notice that I put those grounds
symbols in here in a few places to
indicate that these are those are
objects that we need to make sure don't
get garbage collected so we need to have
some mechanism for keeping those around
that applies to both defense and
reference and the reference queue so
what happens after binary poly becomes
unreachable the phantom reference itself
gets added to the associated reference
queue and that's basically all that
happens the Java object gets immediately
collected there's no longer any need for
it because the phantom reference itself
knows how to clean up so I'll show you a
sort of quick implementation of this
year in in this case this pub actually
is fairly easy so we've modified binary
poly to deal with this sort of reference
cleanup and what I've done is and on the
next slide I'll show you BP phantom
reference implementation that inherits
from phantom references the kind of
phantom reference that specialized with
some additional functionality here and
what this what this does here is we
still have the native delete method that
actually he allocates the C++ object
when I whenever I allocate a binary
object and now do it through this
factory method which allocates via which
constructs and allocates the object but
then immediately goes and registers it
through a static method in VP phantom
reference the way I've implemented it
here now what's pp phantom reference
so that fits on a slide in the same in
the same way that in the sense of the
old Midas commercial if you remember
that but I fetched it to fit it on a
slide here so what that does is it
introduces a couple of static data
structures one of them is the actual
reference cue which will be used to in
cue phantom these PP phantom references
once the corresponding java object is no
longer needed and I also have a need to
have a concurrently accessible set here
some way to just keep the BP phantom
references around so they don't get
garbage collected themselves so I just
keep those around as long as basically
until they explicitly removed and so
what I do then is whenever I whenever I
allocate whenever I can select one of
these PP phantom references I first of
all can select the Phantom reference
giving it the Java object and the
reference cue so that this helps the
underlying phantom reference
implementation to watch that Java object
and put it onto the cue that I gave it
when the Java object goes away and then
I also remember the native handle so I
can actually invoke the allocation
function when it's time so what happens
when I register one of these things I
register Java object and the
corresponding native handle I create a
new BP phantom reference and I added to
my set here just to make sure that it
doesn't go away and then and this is
sort of part of the ugliness of the
scheme unfortunately that we're trying
to address at some point every once in a
while I I actually need to arrange that
everything that's on the reference queue
gets deleted and I've done that here by
providing a method do deletes which just
checks whether there's anything
available for deletion and if so it goes
ahead and deletes that in other context
you may want to do this differently
rather than
just polling whether something is
available you may actually want to
template fed for this and block it sort
of depends on the context it's a little
bit tricky here to do this well in a
loft system because the easy way to do
this is to create a new thread for every
class that does this which may or may
not be acceptable depending on how many
of these you have so then in order to
actually make this work my application
needs to do the following things
periodically in simple cases you can
skip the system GC and system dot run
finalization if you notice that the
garbage collector isn't running enough
because you're not allocating enough
Java objects in order to actually
trigger it you may have to explicitly do
that but usually that's not an issue but
you do have to regularly call BP plan
time reference not do deletes to
actually do the cleanup the way I've
done things here so the next problem
here that I that I mentioned is the
premature and queuing while a method is
still running as I said this is not
actually an issue for Android but it is
an issue for portable code so there's a
partial solution to this in actually in
Java 9 which is this thing called a
teachability fence which you can
explicitly invoke to tell the
implementation don't let the argument go
away yet it's still live to the should
still be live to the garbage collector
even though it might not look it might
not look like it and that's not really
available basically in any
implementation that you can use at the
moment so the best solution that my
colleagues and I could come up with at
the moment is the following which is
relatively simple but not exactly
performance neutral is that is that
instead of having simple methods like
multiply that just invoked the native
method with the native handles what we
do instead is we invoke the native
method with both the native handles and
the java object so what I do instead is
I have a native multiply that takes the
2j object as well
and current implementations though the
spec doesn't 100% guarantee that current
implementations are essentially
essentially guarantee that this and
other turns into a local graph which
tells the garbage collector to keep
these around as long as the native
method is running so things will
actually work out correctly at the
expense of passing additional parameters
to J&I again this is recommended if you
have to write for if you write portable
code for Android I currently wouldn't
recommend doing that eventually sometime
in the future I think we'll have a
better we will probably have a better
solution to this so one more hazard that
I want to go over quickly in pulse
because this actually this is near and
dear to my heart because it sort of took
several months of several people's time
to debug platform code that had this
issue if you're using C++ code in this
way you need to be really careful that
you're actually calling it correctly and
not violating the C++ levels underneath
and that can be quite tricky to do
correctly so in particular if you're
calling C++ code from Java sets it still
has to be fed safe as though you were
calling it for multiple C++ beds and you
have to make sure to follow those rules
this is a bit aggravated by the fact
that some some android framework classes
actually use C++ code internally so this
gets back to the point I was making at
the beginning that you have to make sure
to use those frameworks classes
correctly because otherwise you can run
into this problem even without actually
writing native code and one particular
issue one issue that's particularly
subtle on the C++ side that actually
contributed to this problem that we
spend lots of time on is that often on
the C++ side when you call the leaf you
actually end up invoking some reference
counting mechanism that then takes care
of the underlying C++ objects that I
indirectly reference you have to be you
have to be really careful in that doing
that correctly
I highly recommend using an expert
developed implementation of reference
counting not to all your own I spend a
lot of time recently fixing bugs in
Android platform reference counting
implementations so it's not too likely I
think that most people will get this
right implementing it themselves there
are whole bunch of different issues here
having to do with memory ordering bugs
and self assignments and so on it only
is this tiny amount of code but it's a
really tricky tricky piece of code but
assuming you have a correct reference
counting implementation it's still hard
to use it correctly so one thing you
have to remember for something like the
walls vary a little bit depending on the
implementation but for something like
stitch footer
when you create your shell put it to
something the object will will be
de-allocated when the reference counts
associated with copies of that shared
Potter goes to zero so creating multiple
shell footers to the same underlying to
the same corresponding to the same
underlying bare pointer it's not likely
to work well it's also not likely to
work well to generate a reference
counter pointer to this and they can
selectively for similar sort of reason
because probably by the time you leave
the constructor that reference count
will have gone to zero and you will be
allocate the object before you ever
leave the constructor which is not good
so you have to be careful with that sort
of thing the dead safety walls are in
some ways even more subtle and something
and also something that you really want
to watch out for
so assuming here I have a bunch of
shared photos it's actually okay
according to the normal C++ thread
safety rules if I take X the shell put X
and copy it simultaneously in two
different threads to two different other
pointers this will tie to simultaneously
update the reference count associated
with X but that's okay it's the
implementations job to make sure that
that works correctly so that's that's
fine what's not fine and what in fact
calls the sort of law
extending bugs that we have to deal with
here is the last thing on the slide here
simultaneous assignments to the same
reference counted pointers if I
simultaneously assign even null to the
same reference counted pointer that
looks pretty benign I'm assigning the
same thing concurrently to two different
threads which what could go wrong the
problem is its disallowed by C++ rules
for good reason because what happens
here is both threads will try to
simultaneously the allocated decremented
reference count associated with the
original value of P if they race each
other just right so they both do this
before either one actually assigns no to
the pointer they will end up both
decrementing the reference count which
was originally had a value of 1 because
it was referenced by P that doesn't go
well in the excellent reference count
that Commander's is always there so
summarizing here important point is
avoid finalization use java.lang that
phantom reference instead currently
that's a little bit clumsy but it boyd's
you also the source of potential
headaches it's if you want to read up on
this more I suggest you actually look up
the the Java 9 reach ability fence
contact and discussion that'll give you
a little more insight as to why this is
why some of these things are problem and
particular why you have to worry about
premature premature cleanup with the
Java semantics again not so much on
Android and then stay tuned for future
improvements in this area here if you
allocate a lot of C++ objects if that's
where most of your heat space ends up
getting spent then you should think
about explicit DC triggering but doing
it really carefully make sure you keep
track of how much C++ memory you've
allocated and when you've allocated a
lot so you think it might be useful then
you can invoke the garbage collector so
phantom references for dead objects
getting queued at that point
you can actually do the C++ cleanup at
that point otherwise if you know how not
allocating any Java memory usually the
Java garbage collector will not get
otherwise get triggered and be careful
with C++ memory management and
understand the walls so we actually have
a little bit of time for questions here
if there are any that's the end of it
thank you very much for attending
[Applause]
[Music]